one two
I got really I got my fifth down and I
wanted to hand it back to him because he
kept shouting and shouting and shouting
the minute you give me it I said I'd be
doing everything wrong
and what he said is I've got to make you
even better now than ever before
yeah he takes me to the sushi bar and
he's saying leave it on the mat don't
bring it with you he said I wasn't
shouting I was shouting at you because I
want you to be better
not because you you know I thought I
wanted to give him a fifth down but I
really thought I'd done that
so what I've been doing is I've been
watching somebody on
a film lately and they've been thinking
that Tana hinker is
that's not Tyler Angel because you can't
settle yourself
I've been talking over the last few
seminars in here about Mass
when you go one two you can feel like if
you want to blow your belly up you can
but you can sort of sink into your feet
it gives you time for the mats one two
one two
one two it just gives you enough time to
sync your mats
because if you don't sink your mass my
partner if he's at a good level he'll
know that I've gone up and not come down
so that's good because a lot of the
seniors are shaking their head so you
know what I mean but even as a senior
sometimes I'll go
and I've done it so long you know
but then I'll just thank God
my mind wasn't on this so we're going to
start with Tana henka
it's me it's me itchy